[Music]
so we are in New Orleans and you may
have found love maybe only et was with
bachelor Nick vile in New Orleans where
he went on a romantic one-on-one date
with Rachel in October it was their
first date since she got the first
impression rose
what has it felt like to kind of wait to
go on this one-on-one with him in that
in-between time oh my gosh so Nick will
tell you I I am not a patient person
Rachel's been a kind of a front-runner
since day one and so you know
unfortunately for rage show because I
have a so confident in her and come my
interests in her she kind of had to like
wait a little bit from the very
beginning one of the easiest ones to
just kind of you know talk to jive with
she's just she's so kind of in her
element in any situation and I love a
woman who knows how to have a great
conversation and just has a really
strong personality and a great smile who
are your three frontrunners at this
point Rachel um Daniella someone who
very interested in from the very
beginning she's she's very beautiful and
I think also Vanessa Vanessa someone
that I've also had an interest in we
have a really good really good chemistry
Nick revealing his top three there but
notice controversial contestant Corinne
was not on his list this may explain why
what's going through your head when
you're handing
I want a woman who I can have strong
connection with have great conversations
with I love that physical aspect of
relationships but if you're talking
about a relationship that lasts a
lifetime you need to have that kind of
emotional and cerebral connection so
those are definitely big things that I
look at naked Rachel's date airs Monday
night on ABC
you